also with reaction to our breaking news
tonight former speaker of the house
fox news contributor newt gingrich let
me stay on this very same question mr
speaker if i may
you got the silence of the left all last
summer in the middle of riots all around
the country
then you've got democrats speaking out
loudly about insurrection forgetting the
words that donald trump used many of you
will peacefully and patriotically now
march to the capitol so your voices
may be heard and now silence yet
again over maxine waters comments
uh i i find incredible hypocrisy and
only selective moral
outrage on the part of the democrats and
politics plays
into this because this all leans towards
defunding
and dismantling the police
what there's two different things here
one
is comments like congresswoman talib
who wants to dismantle the police
and close all the prisons putting
hundreds of thousands of violent armed
robbers murderers rapists
back on the street i mean it's a
combination that's virtually
insane the other is what maxine waters
did
i thought that republican leader kevin
mccarthy
was exactly right today to move to strip
her
of her chairmanship look there's a big
difference between the right of free
speech
which everyone has and the
responsibility
that a member of the congress has under
the congress's own rules
and it's very clear that maxine waters
by going to a place that was already
having riots
and making the comments she did in
essence saying
she wanted to substitute the rule of
politicians
for the rule of law she behaved in a way
that i think
absolutely deserves to have her lose her
chairmanship
and every democrat in the house voted in
favor
of defending maxine waters and voted
against
drawing a line in the sand i think it's
a vote that they will regret
because i think the country is pretty
sick of this stuff
and they understand what's going on and
they realize that
you know these are people who are
demagogues
they are liars they're utterly
irresponsible
but what's more important they're
costing the lives
of innocent americans they're
undermining
the ability of the police to function
and they're going to create
a situation where our very civilization
is a threat
from forces that are i think
extraordinarily destructive
let me move towards if we if this effort
we already see massive increases in
the murder rate in many cities now
across the country
after last year's massive increases
we see the defund effort you see the
impact in cities like
new york in places like minneapolis and
minnesota
in places like los angeles dramatic
increases in
in the murder rate and homicide rates i
don't see this ending well mr speaker
you're the historian you're the
professor i don't think you need a
harvard degree to understand where
that's going to end
look i think it's very clear where it's
going to end you're going to have
many americans killed many more
americans wounded
you're going to have a situation and
this is all because of policy
this isn't some random accident it's not
like a thunderstorm in
the middle of the summer you have in
people like
congresswoman talib congresswoman waters
for that matter nancy pelosi herself
you have people whose policies are
getting americans killed
and we need to have a straight up
argument about this these are
terrible policies they are undermining
belief in the police
they are making their seven-year-olds
get killed
driving through a mcdonald's now that
should
tell you that the policy of the
democrats is an absolute
total disaster in terms of protecting
americans
and that is what we're living through
all right we appreciate you being with
us former speaker of the house newt
gingrich thank you